Are you ready guys
areas with barely tape it. Wouldn't wouldn't be there now.
And it wouldn't be the periodic table that we know today. Okay.
So what we're doing today has made or so,
and I'm looking at the periodic table,
looks like an ordinary periodic table. You can take out the elements
we got here. Wow. Kevin is string.
You can imagine the periodic table, but like a family photograph.
There'd be some people who know very well and others where you kept in quick,
you remembered what their name is, but you remember one or two facts about them.
Lecture, theaters, classrooms, all over the world,
have periodic tables hanging in the,
you can buy vodka with Mandalay name on it,
actually produce and show you elemental flourish.
I've never seen so much gold. In fact, I've never seen so much of any elements
inserted the cube into the periodic table of the elements to the chemist.
I've liked to give him card
[inaudible] I'm in India.
I'm on the train going up the Koch about the mountain in Rio de
Janeiro. Nice sunny weather in Stockholm.
Oh wow. I'm on Bondai beach in Sydney, Australia.
So when dumps starts in internally where they made six different super heavy
elements, and I'm just going to show you how they did it,
trying to make literal translation. So the Ethiopians translation,
this is [inaudible] business card and you can see it's a
fun.
I've been told that they need to take one of my has woo.
So each element we'd symbol is four microns across
everything is revealed three,
two, one.
Lovely.
And I'm in the office of URI,
a goodness young after whom element 118
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] whenever he was lecturing the reaction,
he would hold up his hand and say, I had a hand in that reaction.
So a chap called kit, actually.
[inaudible] yeah.
I also found my very first periodic table.